[Music]
it's new stuff yeah
christian's popping bubbles i buy
packing bubbles now what you bought
those separately i bought them with the
purpose of using them to pack no to pop
you're kidding no
i bought a roll of packing bubbles i saw
that from target what
in order to pop them
it was one of the best purchases i've
made all year you must have felt so fat
like luxurious and decadent
uh i don't know if i'd use the word
decadent they're packing bubbles i know
but to buy them just to pop them like
you're some king yeah
well uh here's the show
um
should we just use that uh yeah yeah
life could be a dream
you're listening to life for short i'm
your host justin long life could be a
dream
[Music]
with me as always is my
uh bubble wrap poppin brother
terrible
that's okay you love it so much that you
won't just um
wait for the occasion that you receive a
package with bubble wrap up until this
point in my life that's the first time
you've ever done this yeah usually i
wait for
uh to receive it as like in some it's a
treat yeah it's a treat it's like oh in
addition to like the thing i just got in
the mail which even if you don't like
that thing that much even if they send
you like you know
uh i don't i'm trying to think something
you wouldn't be that into like mascara
that into at all
all in two you give it to maggie you'd
be sort of excited to get over mom okay
but then then you'd be like oh but at
least i have this popping exactly but it
doesn't happen that often where i get a
package that has bubble wrap and
whenever i do get it i'm super excited
and often i've noticed the bubble wrap
has advanced have you noticed this with
bubble wrap it's not the fun popping
yeah anymore it's like that kind of
probably more environmentally friendly
probably yeah well now i'm a little
embarrassed sorry
well you didn't realize it but but the
bubbles have gotten less fun it's harder
to pop them yeah it's not as satisfying
a pop it's just right
exactly yeah
so the other day i was in target with
margaret and almost rhymes target with
margaret yeah margaret and uh we were on
a little i was in target today and we
were uh shopping you know both have to
go to target within the last 48 hours
and i saw this pot this packing
bubbles and i got excited i was like you
know what i'm gonna buy a roll of this
and in the last week it's
it's been such a great decision i've
noticed you popping a lot i thought you
had just received a package no what i do
is i cut a square of it like during i
was watching football i was getting
stressed out i saw that and it's fun
especially the chats when you're
stressed out jets fans know what that's
like yeah so i cut a square and i just
sit there popping i saw you doing that i
didn't really
you know do you know who else pops
bubbles
our guests today
no but you know what i bet our guest
today
um she likes the finer things yeah and
someone who would buy a roll of packing
bubbles just to pop them she was someone
who enjoys the finer thing she wouldn't
judge you for that the way i kind of am
right she wouldn't think it i don't
think she'd think it's weird i guess
today she might she might
i don't know
uh our guest today is
a famous uh bubble wrap popper
bethany frankel
uh bethany you know we were actually
gonna tell a story about how we used to
uh
not used to hang out with paris hilton
but we once found ourselves at paris
hilton's house christian well we had a
summer where we were in her social
circle
summer you think yeah it got to the
point where she made it she knew my name
oh really yeah
and i remember thinking what is my life
right now how does paris hilton know my
name i remember being at her house i
went to like five of her malibu parties
wait was it through holly i don't
remember yeah yeah that's funny i don't
remember that i remember being at her
house and um
she had a big party
and we were like this is weird we're at
paris hilton's house we were with keir
and
uh and
she came out she was very friendly
she was very friendly and she was kind
of like um
you know the show host to sing this
party
can you just say hosting party hosting
has that ever been a thing hostessing
i've never heard that all right she was
hosting a party uh and she had all these
pets she was really into like i remember
a lot of pomeranians and she had these
little tanks with uh then like reptiles
and stuff and one of them was a really
beautiful little and delicate ribbon
snake and i started nerding out over
this thing i was like oh my god you she
had this kind of gecko and and she's
like oh yeah the snake she took out the
snake and
i she said this is what i do with it
basically i it's she's like it's so i
wear it and she put it on it's hot it's
hot she just oh that's right she was
saying it's hot everything well that was
her thing
yeah
so she said about the snack you don't
need to know her to know that she says
that so i'd see we did hang out with her
uh
yeah she put this thing on her finger
and wore it like a ring
and i was um
i was outraged because i was so like the
thought of this delicate little reptile
going to like a red carpet and being but
she said you know she wasn't like
high-fiving people when i was around her
no no she was treating her well he was
still alive it had a very nice life it
had a very nice tank and setting i keep
thinking you're saying taint
um so the reason we're gonna tell that
story that you just told that story the
periscilent story is because bethenny
frankel used to be paris hilton paris
and nicki's
uh nanny that's right i wonder if that's
a no
i think it might be a known thing i
think i'm sure it's a known thing for
people who are aware of
that bethany
the housewife uh nation what is it
called uh probably house uh oh there's a
there's an acronym all right
yeah
our friend and uh
very well known uh i think he's a shorty
friend of the show friend the show jerry
oh a very good friend of the show best
friend of the show jerry o'connell and
sometimes enemy of the show
jerry is um jerry's kind of our source
for all things real housewife because we
don't know the show i make no secret of
my love for the bachelor and i'm a
member i'm a citizen of bachelor nation
i too am citizen yeah you receive your
citizenship because i'm a tribute before
me i think you were watching it but uh
yeah it's true we love it this year with
claire's you don't have to love the
bachelor
uh but jerry we're going to talk to you
afterwards because um he's very excited
that we have bethenny frankel on the
show huge fan very big if you don't know
about uh the real housewives you might
know about her empire her skinny girl oh
writer everyone knows that everyone
knows that skinny girl margaritas which
she no longer owns but she owns the
other skinny girl uh
you know offshoot the skinny universe
and uh she has a new podcast out it's
called just b
with bethany frankel and she has a show
on hbo max coming out oh that's right uh
later this year she's uh got her hands
in a lot of
sorry we keep getting texted by jerry uh
because we are gonna record him soon
he's very excited um and oh and bethany
is also uh she's got an incredible
charitable organization called uh be
strong
and so we'll talk about that we'll talk
about many things
pardon me if pardon b and you had never
met her this is your first time my first
time it was nice to get to to get to
know her and um i hope hopefully you
guys enjoy it uh here it is my first
impression of and with bethany frankel
life could be a dream sweetheart
hello hello again you're booming over
we'll meet again
where are you i'm in connecticut
you watch fairfield do you know it
airfield fairfield do you know what yeah
first of all i know a guy named eugene
who owns catch who just moved to
fairfield county get out and if you know
that i know catch i don't i don't know
eugene but i bought a place
who cares two places in greenwich one
that i renovated that i'm selling
another that i'm going to renovate that
i'm going to keep and live in wow yeah
because i've read that you have to feel
so passionate about where you
any sort of real estate project that you
feel like you need to eventually
potentially live there
that's exactly how i feel about it if i
i don't feel afraid to buy something if
i know that if the hit the fan i
could live right right in a zombie
apocalypse you'll have a really nice
place in greenwich
i would be willing to sell any of the
other ones like all of them that i would
love equally so it could be an
investment but i could also be willing
to live there you know even if places
are some of them are
less
valuable than the others i could take it
all down to just the one but
how do you know that bethany because i
know you got a lot of flack for a place
you got in new york people said oh this
thing is falling apart and there's no
how do you see that potential i'm the
exact opposite i i need everything to be
set up the few times i've bought any
real estate it's like i have a very hard
time
i i don't have a good imagination when
it comes to those things so how where
did that come from that you're able to
see those the potential i'ma very use
what you have a resourceful type of
person like i'm at a restaurant i don't
mind if i order the whole left side of
the menu because i know i'll be able to
take whatever i don't need home and i
can make it into like five different
things so with houses i go in and i like
to see when something really has
potential i don't like something i don't
like to build something from scratch
that's not me nor do i want something
new in cookie cutter i like something
that really looks like it's screwed up
and then no one can vision and i just
have to be able to sort of step back
open my imagination and see
something that other people can't see
which is how you get a great deal
because it looks like a dump but i know
that it's a dump but not a money pit
it's a dump that i can undump and
keep the floors but maybe bleach or
stain them you know which may take ten
tries to get the right color to to to
make those floors work or the cabinetry
is ugly but maybe build on to it and
resurface it so i very much like to keep
something the way that it is and it may
not be what i would have originally
chosen but i always end up what i call
place of yessing it so in the place i'm
in it had a bathroom and the the walls
were just covered in these tiles and
they looked very yellowing but then i
ended up finding um floors that sort of
were marbled but they toned like yellow
and it ended up making the the walls
look amazing so you can kind of play
games to work with what's already there
where do you think that came from that
that i'd call it a gift i read that you
grew up with either a lot or or it was
taken away
you know in the blink of an eye or you
you so you vacillated between having a
lot and then
struggling exactly my stepfather was a
horse both my fathers my real father and
my stepfather were horse trainers right
and the racetrack is a really gritty
place and
it's from drugs to gambling
to highs and lows it's not
it's like down abby where there are the
rich people on the front side and hats
that own the horses but you know the
back of the house is the back side of
the track where the grooms are and
the hot walkers which
i was a hot walker i'll explain that
after but that's you cool down the
horses after they ride on the track
um
my stepfather would you know be making
football bets or horsebacks or would
have nothing or just like would have a
good that's crazy you should get the
track and then you have like everything
so it was very not stable were you even
able to share as a kid were you able to
share in the excitement of the highs i
imagine that that kind of instability
would lead to
uh instability in you i mean like a a
in
um
it's action it's an action i used to be
more of an action junkie but i'm used to
i'm 90 homebody but when i go out and do
something i do it to a 10. i'm just a
very not great type of person black and
white
you were asking about the design that
just came from the first time i ever did
it being able to build something i used
to produce a large scale events
i um even in reality tv if i come in i
get it done so all these things connect
back to just like getting it done that
the horse races there's no second you
just win or it doesn't matter if you
came in second buy a new as you lost so
i have that sort of personality of just
get it done win or don't do it like
there's no grain is it gratifying then
when you do get it done you do quote
unquote win what is that feeling like is
it relief is it joy
is it on to the next it's both i can be
in the moment about things and i do
reflect and i do it's harder now because
so many amazing things have happened to
me starting from the bottom
to you can't every day be reveling and
how wonderful everything is but i am a
person who really enjoys it people that
work with me i've worked with other sort
of major people and say that i do stop
down all the time i'll say oh my god can
you believe this is happening are we
like what how amazing is this like what
are we doing and this just happened
i do celebrate everything but i
celebrate every holiday i celebrate i
took my daughter last night to this big
pumpkin blaze where it's all these
pumpkins and we go to the to the
christmas windows and radio city i'm
just sort of a large is this bryn you're
talking about my daughter
yes so we sell i celebrate everything
aha i see you go all out you go all out
for a celebration i just like to do it
we go it could be anything it could be
we go to tj maxx then we go buy
halloween decorations and then that's
our night we're decorating the house or
we're making stuffed shells and like
it's a big deal we make it it's like
everything's a tradition everything's
great exciting everything's a big deal
even if you don't get something
people always say don't get excited
because you might not get it i'm like
but then i would have not gotten and i
didn't get excited at least i got
excited and i didn't get it like that's
right you got to experience the
excitement exactly yeah so is uh how old
is brynn now she's 10. 10 oh okay so
that's how fun that you get to like
relive those holidays too what were
holidays like when you were 10 like what
was a a halloween like was it
traditional was it fairly normal
no nothing was traditional
growing up because we were always
traveling and always in a new house and
i grew up going to the racetrack and
going to vegas and going to nightclubs
as a young girl wow so nothing was
traditional
but
i mean that's not true there were things
we did every year i mean christmas when
i was a kid for a certain period of my
life was a really big deal and we went
all out and you it was amazing and i
remember that and um
like i said going to the racetrack was
exciting and it was big and so
it sounds like the action like there's
just actually even in the small so you
didn't have negative associations uh or
do you now with things like with things
that are so tenuous like uh
like gambling like the racetrack or is
there an element of that that is still
kind of exciting that still lives in you
it still lives in me when i was broke i
liked gambling a lot more because it
didn't matter if you lost because you
had nothing anyway now i really value
the dollar and know how hard it is to
make i had negative the negative
associations i have are about being
abandoned
and being alone
i'm not
i don't only things that were supposed
to happen that then don't they feel like
they got ruined experiences that got
ruined things that were supposed to
happen that i don't that that's where my
sort of what i call noise
is emotional noise and
i've never really seen
a positive interpersonal romantic
relationship so
as easy as business and decisions and
renovating and all that stuff is
relationships are sort of my place of
wounding okay interesting are you i mean
you came to prominence on this show it's
funny bethany because i like um it's not
a show that i'm aware of but i'm that i
know i'm aware of it but i don't watch
it but i'm also not one of those people
who's like proud that they don't watch
it but i do thankfully have a friend who
does religiously watch it you must know
him you know jerry o'connell i do he
really yeah yes he loves it overly
religiously
it's not religion i think that might be
cult
right he's
and if that is if if that is a cult then
he's the like bhagwan of of
michael rappaport or in like a support
group together oh oh right he's into it
michael wrapper oh my god and chrissy
teigen yeah oh so do you ever run into
like
with jerry for example do you run into
i'm just looking at forgive me i'm
looking down at my phone because our
printer's broken and jerry jerry sent me
all of these great uh he sent me some
questions to ask you that um i'm just
not good well verse then before that do
you when you run into somebody like
jerry or or chrissy teigen
did they just pepper you with questions
and like what why did you get in a fight
with someone so and what you know is it
just endless with jerry it's more
layered because i know him from years
ago also from the racetrack so and i
knew him because i guess i met him in
montauk so we have sort of this
familiarity with each other anyway and
then the show is layered and he'll tell
me
what he thinks michael rappaport
commonly refers to me as the michael
jordan of the housewives so he like
thinks he thinks i'm god i mean michael
rappaport like really loves me
that's good to have him on your side i
guess
yeah
i can see jerry coming up to you and
saying
my guess is that you didn't remember him
from montauk and he was like you know we
know each other from montauk and um
yeah he was i'll try to ask this in his
voice
there was a pretty epic argument between
her and an ex-housewife named carol yeah
everyone has tiffs with friends but uh
does reality television this is a good
question does reality television
exacerbate those differences or does
one in a reality show play them up and
the fights take on a life of their own
now i i watch the bachelor so i'm i'm
well aware of the infighting and stuff
that but but
is it that is a good question do you
feel yourself playing it up or i guess
you can't speak for anyone else but what
is that like well no i have never
come into the housewives and with a
friendship or brought a friend in i
would never do that i'd never like to
get too close to the fire so i've met
these friends doing the housewives and
if we've broken off it's also doing the
housewives some people tend to change a
lot through that experience the fame the
competition you know
it's hard because i've always done it
or it's got to be 100 what's really
going on so some people don't do that
entirely which is their their choice
because now it's become more scripted
than ever but those people choose to
have these things going on off camera
but then they don't want it to come up
on camera so you're living in this weird
hybrid universe that i don't like to
live in uh must be confusing too
i mean what am i allowed to address with
this woman or this person
i want to show this
because last week's season i was a
so this season i'm going to show her
totally oh my god
bethany i've noticed that on the
bachelor there's a guy uh called chris
do you watch the bachelor ever i watched
a little bit i know i'm friends with
tyler cameron
okay yeah yep i've watched that season i
watched i think with my with brennan the
last one but not religiously but i've
watched well to your point i can see
people in fact sometimes they're they're
so bad at reinventing their persona for
the show that they'll literally say
you know
some version of i think i was
misrepresented on the last season then
they show up on bachelor in paradise and
they've got this whole new it's fast
it's really i love watching it's really
fascinating to see how people try to
curate a different personality when
they're not
really equipped to do so you know um
it's very frustrating because not
everyone's playing by the same rules yes
so
that you know that's why i don't know
that that genre in that show but when we
started
i wasn't even wearing makeup the first
season i mean i was am i just you know
normal frumpy clothes because it's a
reality show so we're just being
yourself and the nuances and the small
things were more interesting than now
someone has to slap somebody or rip
their hair out or you know
yeah because people have to raise the
stakes and then it was
the first time you know yeah i was i was
the first person to do a photo shoot on
the show or to to launch up to launch a
book the first housewife then
everything's been regurgitated so many
times so it has to be bigger because
it's the same thing well so so forgive
me i should know this but are you so
you're not still affiliated with that
show you're you don't go on no i love
you
i just left uh i left last year which is
a pretty big sort of disruptive
move i just chose to leave and it was it
was an extraordinary amount of money
that i was being paid so it was an
interesting time to leave and um most
housewives don't leave they're usually
fired but then there's some sort of spin
about it being mutual but it was kind of
a big deal to leave um
especially when i was at the top
in that regard of being paid but i just
left well well it sounds like you have
you had reason to and also you have now
because of your product the skinny girl
empire you have uh it's okay i call it
an empire right it is kind of an empire
at this time and you you make you you're
like an empress an emperor an empress
that's so weird that you just said that
because
i was thinking of these bethanyisms i
was talking about them to somebody and
this morning i was saying to myself
about something the i wrote down the
emperor the emperor i guess it's the
empress or the emperor has closed ah
i feel like i do have clothes sometimes
i felt like i don't but i feel like i
have clothes well well it's part of that
because you're so
trans
you're honest i mean you're up front
like you said the first season the show
you weren't even wearing makeup which is
uh i think in that world kind of a bold
move but it it uh suggests a real
honesty a real upfrontness
um
and and was that part of your impetus
for leaving the show that that there
were all these new rules you had to
navigate and who could i be myself with
and was that a part of it's just not who
i really was it's not conversations that
i would really be having and it's not
who i wanted to be and it's not what i
wanted to portray
anymore i just
there was there were places i wanted to
go in my career
and opportunities that i
believed that i could have and i thought
that that was going to at that point
hold me back it served a purpose for a
while and
um
it was getting to the point where
there's a time do you have to know when
to hold them and when to fold them and
yeah when you overplayed your hand and
when it doesn't seem correct that i
should be there anymore you must have
heard that song a lot growing up the
gambler yes yeah um yes i'm always very
reluctant to ask
guests because it's so nice of everyone
to come on the show to take the time and
oftentimes they're my friends who i'm
talking to so i don't want to like
divulge any
personal information i don't like doing
that myself when i go on these shows was
that ever an issue for you i mean i i
know to be on a show like real
housewives
as you said you're open about things and
you don't have things to hide do you
have a different outlook about that kind
of stuff now having gone through it
having gone through public breakups do
you think in the future would would you
maybe exercise more
i don't know discretion or whatever it
is about relationships see the irony is
i'm a very private person i always have
been and i still am
going through a breakup it is private
but that's not the things in my life
that are the most private what's the and
it's not it's not like big buckets or
categories like my daughter's private
how i feel about things how i process
information how my my my
my plan my strategy
my that's private like it's more the
small stuff is more private to me than
just the big categories like who
i am
you know is more private why
relationships may or may not work for me
is private but that the relationship
didn't work is not private to me and i
made a decision in doing that show
to open myself up and be vulnerable
about what was going on in my life if it
could help somebody else you know that's
the thing
that's why there was a woman who was it
doesn't matter there was a woman who was
on the housewives that was fired and she
was honest about being fired and i
thought that that was admirable
not just because she was being honest
but because it could help other people
because other people especially right
now are being fired so she just
everyone and and and have some false
narrative isn't helping anybody so
people
surgery and lying about it it's not
helping other women it's like you're
hiding and you're pretending
everything's real and that's lying do
your partners do those people ever get
like can we just keep this between us
you know is it ever like does it ever
get because i remember the few times
i've experienced that with paparazzi
with stuff like that i i really hated it
like i really felt it was such an
intrusion and it
freaked me out how do you manage that
because i know you're the subject of a
lot of that uh
dissection and you know you know you
want to divert the message you would
like it to be about your podcast you
would like it to be about what you're
doing but it's don't hate the player
hate the game because you've signed up
for this and you can't have rose and get
only the pedals and get none of the
thorns it wouldn't be fair you probably
get paid to do things a ridiculous
amount of money that somebody else
wouldn't to hold up a popsicle or
something like me and that's the good
and the bad is if you break up with
someone people are going to talk and
explain why and how so it's just the
whole it's all it's the whole little
laundry it's just the whole thing all
together you know and you have a podcast
now so you are going to even be you'll
be talking about more of your life and
and um
it was so funny the first couple of
minutes of the first one i heard
of your podcast i was so excited by what
you were talking about because it's
something i've been talking about with
my brother the last few couple of weeks
i think you were like confounded by the
popularity of the sh of the song
right and i was like oh my god
everything you were saying about it i
was like
yes i can't under i it's i i don't know
if it's just like if this is um a point
of divide between me and this new
generation or what it is this the thing
that like
finally makes me realize i'm old um but
i know it's been blowing our minds
well the thing is
it's the fact that i was willing to talk
about something that i knew was going to
piss people off and have people you know
hey you know come from me but that's why
i decided to do a podcast and i said
same thing i did when i went to
housewives i'm doing it if i'm doing it
i'm doing it yeah yeah you say all or
nothing
so that's what's going on here in the
time when no one's allowed to do that
and i don't really give a good well
well
and i said like i will survive if a
thing gets shut down but
there's a lot of things that you can do
doesn't mean you need to do it and she
she's entitled to do whatever she wants
but people got mad at you for that
people got most people didn't nine out
of ten people went with me and one out
of ten also depends upon the age group
etc yes the thing is i saw it as
yes men have been doing it and degrading
women we haven't liked it so i saw it as
so now we're gonna go to grade ourselves
it's such a fair point i think i should
run for president and go start grabbing
dicks because men have done that
so that i should do that i mean it
doesn't make sense to me
and you're when you're a star you're a
star when your star you can you can do
it you can just grab dicks and fight
yeah i could go outside and show my
vagina right now as a sign of female
empowerment in manhattan but i'm not
choosing to do that so she could do
whatever she wants she's a grown-ass
woman i just had my opinion on it that's
it
it's amazing to me that that's in any
way controversial that's what i'm
discovering now that there's
any controversy about that
uh
and specifically you said oh so funny
about because i didn't know the lyrics
as well you were reading the lyrics and
there was something about um park your
park
what is it a mac truck in my big garage
truck and her tiny garage yes yes yeah
and you go excuse me i don't know how
tiny that garage is
uh
yeah it's true and then the wet the grab
a bucket on a mop then you started
talking about something that we
have wanted to talk about on the show
but you know it's hard to two
two guys to you know sis straight
all the things we are guys white uh
talking about this uh so i'm glad that
you brought it up and i can talk to you
about it but it's true there's a there's
a line grab a bucket and a mop and
you bring up a really great point which
is
well how wet do you need your petunia to
be right like wet is good we've all
decided that wet is good and dry is not
great but like stopping wet like you
need the joy mangano hsn like
retractable mop thing it feels like a
cleaning nightmare yeah there's like
maybe somewhere between like
the gobi desert and the the rain forest
of central america you know like
somewhere they're happy medium moist
drinking waters it's not
maybe once a year but that seems like a
very hard thing to maintain
oh yeah waterfall every time you try to
get laid
and just hygienically
it can't be
um
you have to have a full-time housekeeper
petunias you need a mop person you need
somebody with and you need a specific
bucket and a mop you can't just use any
no you have to have one designated for
petunias oh wait i don't think you would
do your floors with that too so now you
have to buy a special piece of equipment
i agree i agree well this is gonna
invite a lot of controversy we're gonna
get a lot of letters
life could be a dream sweetheart
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the
[Music]
does that kind of reach that you have
ever
intimidate you or or make you feel give
you pause to say certain things the fact
that you know your words your views may
be picked up in a way that that is
public listen you're talking about it
now it doesn't matter what it is we're
talking about people need
us to talk about it because otherwise
we're ending up in the handmaid's tale
and everybody's got masks on that
they're zipping their mouths closed
because people are afraid i know some
pretty
successful people who have big
followings who are all of a sudden now
like oh i went off social for a little
while because i said that about that
meghan markle and and the mega knights
or the sussexes or whatever they came
after me or i said that about that and
my thing is and if you listen to my
other podcast i think that was the one
with bozuma with sia in the beginning i
was out to you know
my instagram story was live and she and
i were spilling the tea
and the restaurant manager came in and
let me know because i have such good
fans to let me know the point is i
looked at her and we went through it all
for a second and i thought about who we
had talked about what we had said and i
said to her
they're not paying my rent so if
they're not paying my rent i'm saying
what i feel because someone's got to say
that they feel i don't have to be right
i have an opinion
so so disagree with me don't bully me
disagree and let's have a conversation
on real housewives when they started uh
when you attempted to do that cause you
strike me as somebody who would make
that effort to okay you disagree with me
let's have an exchange about it would
they ever gin you guys up and like uh
try to get you to go at it
the thing about it is the genre of
television is a zero-sum game at all
times someone needs to be winning and
someone needs to be losing
when you see that someone's starting to
lose people prey upon that person and
get excited because it's something that
they can all do and it means it's off
them it's hot potato yes they smell
blood right now i'm not the bad person
you are so we're all going to go over
there i've seen that
oh my god i've seen that it's
fascinating to watch on um on the
bachelor you can see
some of these people men and women just
smelling blood in the water and it
becomes very primal it becomes very like
it's like watching a nature show you
know and
so if you get a nugget of something that
everybody can cling to to go that
person up
everybody's gonna go do that you know
that's what happens i have been against
the grain so many times of that and i
never really care because i always stick
to who i am and it served me well are
the producers ever explicit because i've
i've been around some of these sets and
i know their degrees of how they direct
you um how much they how much direction
they give but how explicit does it get
like did they say
hey go after her is it ever that is it
ever like no it's a
reminder you should talk to
derinda about what was said at the party
it's a reminder or they'll tell they'll
show one person an article that was
written about another person
brought into the show but they're not
telling you what to do not what they
described on the hills they're not
saying we'll give you a birkin bag if
you get into a fight with someone or
we'll give you a bonus well it's not
like that yeah i'd rather that you're
gonna give me a birkin bag i'll
somebody up
that's a bethanyism that could be a
bethanyism um i i uh did you
it's interesting that you said they're
actors like now it requires some sort of
acting
um
skill i guess to to participate in a
show like that and that's why i love the
bachelor because i've noticed that more
and more they're they're
they're very clearly acting and and in
in most cases poorly i think they're
like it's bad improv it's
so i i often see that the producer has
said to them it's clear that they said
talk about like you said talk about this
thing
and they bring it up in such a
parsing reality uh it's not acting it's
sort of like more like
soft scripted you know i'm not going to
bring up the fact that i'm dating this
person over here so that's going to stay
over there but and here i'm going to
share this with you and with everybody
else it's just parsing it's not it might
be
yeah but it might it might be semantics
but i think i would define that as
acting i think that's okay
this is my show bethany and i think it's
actually i agree i just wanted to make
sure we understood the same definition
of it yeah yeah no but it's it's really
fascinating um
uh a friend of mine also said that you
are i find this so interesting you were
super allergic to fish
definitely allergic it's like i'm
telling you that you don't know this
yeah
yeah i almost died uh two years ago i
think it was bad oh my god to all fish
bethany uh
i can eat anything under 13.99 a pound
i'm allergic to but i can eat shellfish
i can eat sugar i can eat how convenient
crab all that oh great
oh so it's the like tilapia or mahi
white fish white fish
salmon fish yeah so how was it
how did you discover this and and and
what happened two years ago
as a little kid i discovered it i think
um
when i was a little like a baby i picked
up a piece of fish off the floor that
someone had dropped or feeding the
dolphins at sea world and had to be
hospitalized but as an i i just from
touching it touching it
touching it
but as an adult it's sort of i thought
it had tempered i guess there's a thing
that they that what i didn't realize and
it's counterintuitive the more at the
more exposure you have to the allergen
the worse the allergy gets and so it can
and it's just counterintuitive so
i just thought in my life over the
course of time that it sort of was
getting better yeah and sometimes i
would touch something reason and my face
would blow up and i'd have like a black
eye or something but it would take
benadryl and would go down and that was
maybe once or twice a year but on the
occasion last year i drank miso soup
which i didn't realize was with bonito
flakes and my hand just started to itch
and i said to my boyfriend i feel itchy
but it wasn't a big deal at all it was
like very nothing and he said you want
me to get you benadryl and i didn't want
to be knocked out and i said i don't
know but i immediately passed out and
was unconscious for
15 minutes my blood
60 over 40. i was hallucinating i was
i was i was within five minutes of dying
i was rushed to the hospital and they
said that had been five minutes later i
would have died oh my god
really bad
oh you do i was going to say yeah so
your throat closes up that's uh it's an
anaphylactic shock
uh
yeah and uh god in heaven yeah really
bad
um i'm curious what advice you would
give yourself at 18 and then again at 30
because those seem to be
pivotal moments in your life uh
and and
what would you say to 18 year old
bethany
i just don't think 18 year old bethany
would have listened but i okay
i think i was definitely asked about
like i think maybe in my 20s i would
have listened if i really if someone had
really made me understand
that
you don't need to have your life tied up
in a bow and know what the path is you
people in their 20s think they're old
they think that they need to get married
they think they need to know what their
career is they really get nervous you
know and and i'm more than 20 years
older than that and i still don't feel
like i need to know everything but i
really did back then so i think
just letting your 20 year old self know
that you do not need to have a
relationship or a career or anything
really wrapped up then you have to be on
the road moving forward that's good
advice that's good yeah i i think for
any age really that's kind of good
advice how old are you
42 i'm 42. and i would say the same
thing as you were saying that i thought
oh yeah that'd be good advice for
but i don't i don't know that 18 year
old justin would have listened either
what do you know old man yeah like i got
the world by the balls i'm gonna do it
um you're just
you're just old uh well
having and you came into what you are
now very wealthy because the skinny girl
stuff all the stuff that you've done
does having that kind of financial
independence now does that just
what does that feel like to you what is
that
how is that manifested in your
personality or in your
day-to-day life do you just kind of is
it easier for you to chill out
um
you feel a safety net it's easier to
well it's something to navigate having a
child because she doesn't oh right how i
lived and how stressed out i was about
money i mean my daughter is the nicest
sweetest the most well-behaved everyone
loves her adults love her kids she's
just
next to perfect i mean she just has it
like people i took her last night out
with a bunch of grown-ups and every time
i take her with grown-ups they call me
and said oh my god that child is like
special she's got something so my point
is i get her anything she really wants
because she's just such a pleasant
lovely person if we're out somewhere she
likes something i'm like yeah sure i
mean i'm not getting her ferrari did you
make an effort to
to distinguish between
uh you know just have being able to have
anything she wants and and having to
work for like how where did that come
from how did you instill in her uh a
niceness i guess well when i say what
she wants she likes art supplies and
she's not materialistic at all and she
doesn't you know
tick-tock or anything she doesn't want
expensive things just you know and
she'll she'll hold back and she'll say
sure mama i just got one thing you know
she just somehow has it innately because
i understand the value of money she
knows i do a lot of relief work i talk
to her a lot about uh how hard i would
work for everything that she has and
that we have and why
you know so she just has a keen
understanding of what's going on
but money makes it that i can
do a private tour at disney if i were
going i don't have to wait on lines and
that i really the only time that money
really and connections really matters to
me
is when it's something
for her and i and privacy and like ease
in that way it's not like yeah no i use
it's not a day-to-day
it's not a day-to-day i mean i go in
bursts of buying things and i have
really nice things but then the pandemic
really made me stop
purchasing luxury things because it just
felt gross didn't it yeah yeah you know
it just felt like not important it was
weird your charity uh it's called be
strong and they've brought tons of uh
millions of just millions of dollars to
disaster relief and now you're doing it
with uh for covid how did that come to
be uh and what was the impetus for that
foundation it's an initiative called be
strong and it started with hurricane
harvey and we've been all over the world
from the amazon
to puerto rico probably six times
yeah all over the caribbean all over
guatemala yeah
and we've distributed
in excess of 50 million dollars of aid
and it's just me and really one other
person just killing ourselves and for
covet you did 20 million units of um
ppe we
we hit every single state in the country
and hospitals fire stations we did 2
million
1 million hazmats 1.1 million hazmat
suits and 1 million masks uh very early
on when the government couldn't couldn't
pull it together and
we are a run and gun sort of startup
operation
because i'm an entrepreneur and able to
get a lot of things done and just
execute like we talked about in the
beginning of the show um i'm able to
execute that and it's been the greatest
mark i've been able to have
in the world
and i've given you things the just be
with bethany podcast is just
like several people said no to me or
didn't call me back about doing one and
then the person who called me and said
they wanted to do it i said sure
and i didn't think i was even gonna make
any money i didn't know there was a
metric i didn't know there were lists i
didn't know there were like much data
and it's
things that you just love to do and that
you're passionate about and then be
successful at them did you ever have
aspirations to be uh
an entertainer or to go into a business
like this to be an actress let's say was
that ever you did
yes but i then realized i wanted to be
myself and this genre didn't exist back
then so i didn't want to be confined by
a script or even hosting felt like sort
of also constricting in a different type
of non-genuine way
so
this is all like falling into place
really nicely and late in life that
reality television was one vehicle and
then having this amazing podcast is just
as you know another incredible vehicle
so fun
really unexpected i i'm shocked i read
that you um knew the elder hilton
daughters and you babysat for paris
hilton
and nikki and
did when when they started getting into
reality the reality world was that um
was that something that you looked at
and thought oh you know that might be an
avenue for me to me i had no idea it
even applied to me they were i hadn't
spoken to them in you know regularly for
years and they were so from another
planet in that success that it
definitely didn't apply to me i just
wanted to be a natural food chef and i
wanted to be on the food network and the
head of the food network at the time
told me it was never going to happen
why why did he give you a reason why
no i kept approaching i would watch tv
and then see the production companies
and try to just call them and contact
the production companies and they liked
me and they would then approach him and
he bought said
no just it's not going to happen for you
you're not right and you're not going to
be on television so he said that and
that's happened now in the pod it
happened in the liquor space
where it happened in the podcast space
even at this level of success i had been
told by you know i i was blown off by
scott greenstein it's serious and
you know liz blakely had spotify started
but you don't remember names or anything
or like nope i remember exactly i'll
always that's a list of people yeah okay
well they're like oh god well i'm glad
we uh i'm glad we had you on i'm glad i
didn't blow you off uh we we so that
could be another bethanyism that um
maybe just don't say no to bethany that
that could be
that's something that people should have
learned i guess hold on
oh bethany's showing me her oh she just
redirected
the camera to a neon sign that says i
know it all
literally there's just a sign on her
wall it says i know it all
well
uh we are very different in that regard
we have similar feelings about uh wet
ass petunia by cardi b
but very different in that regard that
that's very um
i just said it on the housewives this is
a jerry o'connell special tell him you
saw the wall on the housewives someone
said you're not on i said well maybe i
know it all and if you want to know some
of it all come ask me and it was a
famous sort of line it was popular
i don't think i know at all well okay so
bethany this is a good example of uh is
it that line when you say something like
that which has caught on it's a great
line um
are you aware
is it like you said you don't really
think that so is it something that
you're consciously
playing up is it like oh i'm gonna
i i got a good z i got a zinger no no
there's this line that i said where i
said mention it all and i don't remember
saying it when i'm in the zone and i'm
filming i don't remember anything i say
later people are like clinging to this i
know it all thing i wouldn't even
remember that that night i sometimes
think i said something great and it
wasn't anything that anyone else even
jumped on so no do people when they
approach you do they ever they they must
feel like they know you they must feel
like very familiar with you
um
just
does that ever
do you ever think that they're
approaching somebody
else and by that i mean do they ever
does it ever feel like they're talking
to your persona and and not to you
really
no because i'm really i'm exactly the
same okay yeah so that's what makes it a
little more scary because yeah oh my god
and bethany we're the best friends and
i'm just like like because i forget that
i'm i'm always home i'm a homebody i'm
always i don't leave the house and i'm
always in pajamas so when i do go out i
forget that i've gone someplace into
this other sort of species of people
where i'm famous
and they know
like so it's weird not only do they
well not only do they recognize you but
they know
the nuances of fights that you've been
in and relationships that's got to be
strange jarring
wow that's one two sometimes but you
gotta be prepared like if you can't walk
into like a food festival
not pre-covered like a big mall or
something like and i know who my people
are like you know i don't know i know
who my people are so if i were a certain
type of place i'm like these are my
people yes like
where's
so where's the quintessential you
mentioned a food market
a mall wheelhouse a food court
wheelhouse like a like a food and wine
festival
broadway like a theater oh yeah
you know
those are my people
yeah my friend sharon feldstein
jonah hill and beanie feldstein their
mom sharon um
i would yeah i think would really freak
out on you um
you know
feel like a barbecue restaurant like in
chicago your p a lot of your people
would be there uh yeah you know i did a
lot of movies in the in the like mid
2000s that were kind of frat type movies
um
like you know some of those comedies
were uh a lot of frat a lot of college
kids had that so
it depends i mean i've also yeah i guess
it just depends on what people but i
always know i usually know roughly what
people
know me from you know like if it's uh
what genre or whatever whatever uh but
for you it must be tenfold just with
people knowing things about your life so
many things
well also you know it's interesting
the types of people that are that know
you
are very different types of people you
know
my my group my female army they're
awesome they're like they're moms
they're nicely they they're they're
sensible in how they spend they're not
overly superficial but they are always
polished and put together they're
interested in business like i said
they're fun they have a sense of humor
their moms and like are cute and fun and
have a drink like if there's a bunch of
girls having
a girls night those are nice that's kind
of nice and you find them i remember uh
an ex
of mine used to say um she's an actress
and and
she would get it
you know much worse than i would when it
came to people
recognizing herself and i remember she
said once look at it this way we can
walk into any bar anywhere in the
country
and
meet people easily and like get and have
a you know and i'm a sociable person uh
i and i wasn't seeing it that way i
wasn't seeing the positive and just
being able to connect with them see i'm
not that sociable and you seem not
sociable oh well i've gotten
uh it's funny i've i've gotten less so
but i love going to a bar i used to love
this going to a bar
and just me i used to love just meeting
people having some are you single or
married i'm single you are yeah how's
single life in fairfield connecticut oh
it is oh it's hopping
it's insane imagine a lot of those moms
are digging you like the cute do you
have
oh you know what's funny i say i'm
sociable i enjoy
socializing
but i do i haven't been i don't i don't
um i'm socializing it under uh certain
certain terms you know socializing i
think socializing now when i if i go out
to a bar
people have preconceived it's not as
pure as if i were to go out with friends
i guess i just mean more like the old
days you know going out with friends
um well connecticut has some cool bars
i'm hearing oh it's great yeah and you
mentioned your friend
who owns catch which is a great
restaurant just moved here yeah no i i
love it i just don't go out a lot
there's a place called grey barns it's
supposed to be cool i wanted to try have
you heard about it yes south but no i
have not tried it i'm in southport
really so it's it's between fairfield
and westport if you know that uh
okay how far are you from greenwich uh
probably about 30 minutes 35 minutes
okay so i'm surprised why that place is
supposed to be it feels like
it feels like it's like trying to be
like a soho house farmhouse in london
like the place grey barn that's what i'm
trying that's
it's right around the corner from me
bethany yeah well if you ever come here
let me know we'll uh okay that's norwalk
right you're near okay now let's just
give your address might as well
your whole life
exactly life could be a dream sweetheart
hello hello again
we'll meet again
[Music]
all right my producer's saying we are
running out of time
i'm sorry if we go over a little bit but
this is just a lightning round bethany
okay
uh this is the best interview you've
ever had so obviously you want to go
longer i understand exactly i want to
milk it clearly um
what is your most commonly used emoji
i'm the i'm not tech i don't even know
how to i barely know how to turn my
phone on but i guess
when you say exo and then the kissy face
the kissy lips are everywhere
no stop the stop sign someone's going on
and they're i'm like and they're just
not saying the right thing they're
annoying i just put the stop sign up oh
i don't think i've ever used that but it
that would you know why
do it if it's for the right thing just
do it just do it to somebody just it's
so powerful
no you know why because i would be the
one that would have that sent to me
yes i would i could stop myself maybe
maybe if i was texting too much
let's say you you you met a girl and she
was insecure and she was like i just
feel like you're not you know you don't
care a lot and you know
you know it's all about you or you know
you don't you don't you don't you don't
love me
stop
stop stop
i like that it doesn't have to be a
great it could be like it's not
aggressive yeah it could be affectionate
yeah stop i'm not stop you
exactly stop i like that um okay wow god
it's so funny i've never used that one
i i will
um
if you could be a professional athlete
you mentioned uh um you grew up around a
lot of horse racing and but by the way
do people ever people must get upset
about the horse racing things i know
not
not a ton and i'm glad that they have
come to me but they're not like thinking
i'm responsible for all but i was just
right you're not which you're not if i
could be a professional athlete
i would be a professional sleeper my the
super power that i would like to have
would be able to be like great at
sleeping me too
that i was good at not
me i know god i i envy those people who
can just
go out
for your superpower on command it could
be yeah in fact
and and what was the second thing
sleep in a car you're in a car boom now
it's time to go to sleep
oh man i i know i gotta have a earplugs
now and then machine lavender the whole
thing i know you guys you do all
that do you have a secret do you have a
trick do you have anything that did work
well the comment works if you do the
getting back to sleep falling gently
into sleep breathing inhaling and
exhaling like slowly and intentionally
it's hard to get to 25 without falling
asleep
a little
like cbd edible helps like i've got a
whole you know the whole spiel do you e
do you you mentioned cbd do you ever
have th do you ever eat weeds
edibles i think cannabis is amazing
space for pain relief sleep and
relaxation not for getting high for just
like let's go to sleep and not be taking
pills like ambien or opioids i mean
opioids uh what do we call it colon pain
or stuff like that
right
no i've been taking over the counter you
know like tylenol
advil pm whatever and i don't even like
taking that but it makes you feel zonked
out the next day yeah
yeah if you could have one snack food
speaking of
eating weed
um
a go-to
by the way i swear to god in my life and
i'm bringing it up now but it's my ski
i'll send you all this my skinny
girl microwave popcorn nothing touches
it it's oh really it's yes it's not
overly oily it's just good salty snack
it's really good you'll see okay
that'd be great uh
oh yeah skinny girl so skinny girl is
not just cause i remember it being just
it was a margarita mix it was like a
margarita so much it's so much more it's
dressings it's preserves it's shapewear
it's apparel it's popcorn we're coming
out with um pots and pans and uh
sleepwear and glasses it's it's a whole
unit oh wow and i so i could be a skinny
boy
you could
you could unleash
unleash your skinny girl yeah yeah why
not i'm single i can explore i'll
explore my my own space
um
what what is your what's your favorite
movie of all time or
i think a better way to ask that would
be in in quarantine bethany is there a
movie that has brought you a lot of
comfort that you've you were excited to
share with brynn
well sadly i should not be saying this
aloud because child services will come
and there's some inappropriate scenes
but my daughter really took to the wrong
missy
during quantity oh
anything inappropriate step brothers
mike and dave's wedding anything by the
way you're a genre i believe she's wait
any we call it like what do i call it
like um not idiot movies
so you've been intimidating right
have you been in oh yeah movies that's
my specialty
yeah so she loves an idiot movie oh man
yeah
oh oh she loved this idiot
so i can say
if she
like yeah if she's uh yeah do you know
the city
hey brandon
we gotta watch more of your movie i was
literally in a movie called idiocracy
that's you can't get more idiot-y than
that
um
which we're all sort of living right now
yeah yeah well so separate oh god i love
step brothers well that's great i i'm
trying to remember when i was 10 what
the boundaries were with movies but my
parents were pretty
i guess they were pretty strict about
that kind of stuff uh but step brothers
like i don't know i i have no from a
reference too much but you know i wink
wink edit out the bad parts maybe not oh
yeah yeah
um
and and what about you your favorite
movie if what's the movie that you just
i love
wall street the shining
redemption i loved american beauty i
love the big chill
yeah yeah great movies
classics yeah
um
i don't yeah i like things that seem
sort of possible
have you ever been approached by
something like i'm now thinking of
actors in those movies like like tim
robbins or somebody
approached by somebody who was like kind
of fanning out over you that surprised
you it was like anthony sir anthony
hopkins or somebody
ricky gervais or emma
stone or reese witherspoon
i'm shocked by these people and it's
only happens if someone invites me to an
award show or something and then i go
and then
like
these people know me like ike barron
holds like i love you
when somebody like uh emma stone or
ricky that would those people approach
you is it ever do they ever couch it in
with um any sort are they ever coy are
they ever like sort of embarrassed that
they're like really into the no
no yeah
yeah yeah all the way in yeah they love
it that's that's funny that's cool um
surprise mike tyson
yeah and one of the like it was i think
it was chris wade one of those guys was
like a huge fan it's always funny when
you get like that like mike tyson are
like a crit i think it was no is it
chris not quite
not dwyane wade
dwyane wade
i went to miami at the same time
it's either chris bosh lebron james
those guys
wow it's funny um if you had to live
somewhere else where would it be
italy
yeah yeah you've been i'm guessing italy
yeah or like uh
maybe
northern california
a lot
you do yeah jerry goes out there a lot
he's always uh jerry lives out there
like i like it a lot
and so you spend some time there over
the summer you're in the hamptons yeah
and i go year round i just like i like
the freedom i like the air i like the
view i like i like
i like the suburbs believe it or not i
like the country i don't i do too
yeah it's nice right yeah ah it's the
best yeah the the air and the quiet i
i just love it um
it's so funny this pandemic is
you know it's it's it's revealed certain
truths about
how i feel about life i i again this is
privileged to be able to even like say
this but when everything slowed down and
really stopped
it it it started to illuminate the
important things and and uh and the
things that i was chasing that was
probably
it wasn't bringing me joy really you
know and people too you learned a lot
about people
yeah if you could have dinner with three
people dead or alive whom you've never
met
mark zuckerberg would be one of them
yeah um
i still think yeah well hillary said she
wanted to go for coffee so i'd like to
meet my god
dinner so now mark zuckerberg so you're
on the press precipice of being friends
with hillary
let's just call it what it is you're
like she's really cool she was wearing
like a fleece that any human being in
vermont is wearing in in december i was
wearing a snoopy t-shirt we had a cool
conversation she was really great she
didn't ask for any of the questions
um okay really quick who's your favorite
muppet
muppet kermit
kermit yeah yeah
of course yeah he's definitely a muppet
what do you think he's a real what did
you think he was
you know but i meant like i thought
maybe the muppets were like his friends
and he's like the main guy
he's an actual frog but yeah he's the
main muppet yeah
he's the boss muppet he's the boss bish
he's like
yeah yes uh if if you had to be one age
for the rest of your life you could pick
one age physically knowing what you know
now
being as evolved as you are don't give a
i don't give a
if you could be reincarnated as a
non-human animal what would you be
um
one of my dogs
oh dog you're one of yours
okay uh would you rather be called
what kind of dogs do you have
lhasa no they're not i just made that up
they are rescues that were their mom is
going to be euthanized and they are 15
pounds different but the same litter
biggie and smalls
oh oh that's great
that's really funny
i had a dog named biggie smalls once a
little tiny guy yeah isn't that funny i
mean there's only one dog
and my mom called me once and she said
like months into owning this dog i i
rescued it for my parents and it was
theirs really but she said did you name
our dog after a gangster rapper well i
got a lot of for that this week a
little because of the whop thing
but i have dogs named biggie smalls i'm
like they are dogs they're not rapping
they're dogs
the notorious dog you can change them
yes yes um which uh which golden girl do
you most identify with dorothy blanche
rose or sophia oh mod
mod yeah dorothy
yeah you
you're totally dorothy uh yeah
dogs dogs are cats
dogs i think dogs sure and the beetles
are the rolling stones do you prefer
yeah okay um so sorry i'm racing through
all this uh it's so fun talking to you
though uh that was really interesting
i'm getting thank you i know you're
publishing
really fun yeah what's next what are you
are you on the publicity circuit
yeah we're just we keep keep promoting
this just be with beth anything i'm
obsessed with i live for it because it
was a surprise i start shooting the big
shot with bethany next two weeks which
is a show like a modern apprentice on
hbo right html max
hbo max so cool okay modern day
apprentice and and where can people
donate to be strong it's such a great
just go to bethany.com be strong
so cool it's really cool you're doing
that and um it's cool that you did the
show thank you for taking the time thank
you so much
okay all right and let me know when you
come to town i will i'm coming next week
i'm excited i'm really excited so i'm
excited to be a connecticut height
come on by that'd be fun okay we'll get
some coffee all right cool
well that's just how that happened
happened
long island
when did
we start just imitating the oh i don't
know we don't have to do that every time
but it's okay you know i don't think
it's a bad idea i just i was wondering
when we started that uh because some
guests are really hard to imitate i
don't know when we started doing that uh
bethany frankel anyway regardless yeah
what'd you think
i really enjoyed talking to her she was
a very she was easy to talk to
yeah you guys had a nice rapport yeah
you know it's funny with some guests
i've noticed even friends of mine they
draw very clear boundaries which is
totally fine they don't want to talk
about um
you know like tom i uh joel they didn't
want to necessarily talk about family
there's certain things and i have a very
hard time i don't like making respecting
boundaries no
no thanks
i have a heart well sometimes i have a
hard time um
i don't want to make people feel awkward
i i'm very like uh you know i've so i'm
afraid of delving too deep like i was
just watching this
i was just watching a dick cabinet
interview with george harrison which is
amazing and he
dick cavitt is so good at that he's he's
so kind of cavalier about
bringing up potentially
um
uh
tricky like sticky s
topics
yeah whoa
yeah but but with george harrison he
brings up like almost right off the bat
he brings up yoko ono and he and he's
like so he was he makes it a joke he
like works it into casually in
but i
really admired that that he was able to
like go to potentially
um
revealing places i just i i can't do
that well you know our friend our mutual
friend alex uh
when this show first started when life
is short first started he texted me and
he said uh you know justin reminds me of
dick cavett justin on this show reminds
me of dick oh my god i thought that was
a very high compliment
yeah i
think it's too high so you're saying uh
with respect to bethenny frankel she
does not seem like someone you have to
tiptoe around is that no as you were
saying yeah i found myself tiptoeing and
then i realized that
this is kind of
what made her known is revealing so much
and
and so my just my natural instinct
to avoid that um
was was not warranted you know i i
needed to kind of like work against it
in other words and so
that was that was refreshing getting to
you know
getting to ask her
things about personal things that
normally i'd feel uncomfortable asking
yeah she um
i you did the thing where
first of all i thought it was a really
good conversation and
she it was impressive to me she's very
sure of herself and uh
you know she is she's very like i like
her all or nothing
i i don't i don't like it in so far as i
i could ever live that way but um
because i
like gray areas too much
but she i kind of appreciate the fact
that she is
lives a very
you know black and white
life where it's like it's like win or go
home you know and she's i she has that
drive and that uh there's something that
i
am impressed by you know people who
have who are able to do that well
doesn't it i mean considering how she
grew up and
yeah that sort of makes sense it's like
that's racing that's what horse racing
is it's like you don't get there's no
prize for second place speaking of that
you
you missed such an he's such a layup pun
wait wait let me guess let me guess
because i sometimes i kick myself
tell me what the setup was uh her
childhood and
her stepfather and how she said i'll
just say it she said she her childhood
was very unstable
as she was talking about the horse
racing oh you wanted to be more stable
yeah yeah yeah that's good
and you also did the thing where um
when you do this every single time you
talk to someone that you're not aware
that you're not familiar with you do you
apologize no you do your research
and talk to you which is good it's good
to do research i know what you say yeah
i talked too much about the thing that i
watched or listen you talk too much
about this the research you've done
and
you become very proud
of the research so
yeah so many times you made me laugh so
hard you were like
i read that um
you and at one point she was like yeah i
was um you know shopping with my
daughter and she was in the middle of
the sentence you go oh your daughter
brynn
and then she was talking about her
charitable organization and she was like
we do work in um the caribbean you're
like the caribbean yeah yeah nicaragua
guatemala yeah yeah i'd read about it
i'm proud very proud i want her to know
that i had resp you know respected her
enough to do some research yeah yep do
you know who does respect housewife
nation i sure do we're about to call
yeah okay so let's hear from because
christian and i are
really not well-versed i'm almost
completely unfamiliar with that whole
world i've seen i think the extent of my
expertise is clips from the soup
oh yeah i think that's former lifestyle
uh guest joel mchale
oh
yeah
the boys are back
welcome back to the podcast yeah it's
good to have you back it's been it's
been too long it's been a minute yeah
about that i actually um i don't know if
you know this but i was in kenya for a
month wait yeah i want to hear about
this wait uh
what a month
yeah my wife did a movie and um
i mean there's no school you know
there's no physical school so um wow
we just uh so you were the teacher
are they doing any covet protocol there
well you know it was a movie it was a
major movie so they tested everybody
twice a week and we all stayed at the
same hotel
and um
i mean yeah wow
you can't come into the country unless
you have you get to quarantine
negative test you have to quarantine i
think their quarantine is four or five
days you know as opposed to the yeah
that you've been hearing about what
what's it like out of it were you in um
uh not what was the
went to southern capital
a park called ambaseli and then northern
kenya a park called uh shabba wow a
month i can't get over that and the kids
must have loved it
i mean it's really funny everyone said
when you go to africa you'll never be
the same and you really you're never the
same it's really gorgeous i just i i
can't uh
it's just um
it's just different like like the soil
is different everything's different the
air
the air is different the sunsets are
different it's just different it's just
different not as much paparazzi
uh not as much paparazzi you know i
don't know if you know this but uh
um i spoke to your former co-star
lindsay lohan for a little tv show i did
for cbs
my wife rebecca and then
i colored my wife's hair
how did you know how to do that
i didn't um i zoomed with her colorist
oh oh wait how'd you then how did you
having to talk to lindsay
because we also um
gave lindsay lohan with the help of her
stylist a blowout
how did you how did you do that if it
was on zoom
we did it to zoom i interviewed her
did you talk about when we ran into her
at uh the cabin down below
uh i actually i didn't mention that i
knew i did not i'm sorry i i sort of we
should let your listeners know what
you're talking about
justin christian and i went to a bar in
new york
and lindsay lohan came in with her
entourage i think she was leaving buddy
wasn't she leaving as we were getting in
but i was there and i was like whoa
check it out lindsay lohan and um
lindsay lohan at that point made a
beeline for justin i couldn't believe it
i forgot that they had they started
together and herbie the love bug yeah
yeah and um
lindsay grabbed justin by the cheeks and
squeezed them much like uh
an uncle would
to their niece or nephew
and like puckered up his lips and then
on justin's lips it was crazy everyone
on justin's lips whispered very close to
his face
my love and then
kissed him square
on the lips
i can verify it yeah you can verify i
was two feet away from that i was less
than two feet away from me
it was crazy and then lindsay and all of
her people just like swept out of there
i mean yeah yeah as quickly as it
happened she was gone and
yeah and justin um just left there still
with his lips like pucker just like left
like frozen you know i've never seen
such a huge star interact with justin so
intimately
except for ann margaret you know then a
couple days later jerry did i tell you
this i got violently ill
like i got true that is true that's
absolutely you get like 104 degrees yeah
yeah jerry i swear to god i got sicker
i'm not saying it was lindsay who did it
but i got i was sicker than i had been
in recent memory
anyway um speaking
i am calling because you have a huge uh
i'm gonna i'm gonna say this right right
now
i mean no offense to of course nick
kroll or uh you've been listening
you've been listening
oh gosh uh
no offense to uh alexandra
oh you've been listening thank you
joel
these are prices whoa you
have
nathan lane oh my god oh my god um
but i gotta say
anthony frankel may be the biggest guest
on life is short yeah okay so jerry
we've we've told everyone if they don't
already know that you're a huge what do
you call yourselves a real housewives
nation
uh a roni a row knight
um
like a real um like a housewives fan
i'm more of a fan of
the network of bravo you love bravo yeah
so you do a lot you're on andy cohen
you're first of all i'm not just i'm not
just a bravo fan i also love a show
called 90 day fiance which i suggest you
guys oh we like that you know you should
call yourselves bro bro
maybe
uh i used to call myself a bravo bro
uh-huh but
that does it it alienates gender yeah
that's true
that's true you hate assigning gender
so i didn't i want to apologize if
anyone is offended by me saying
that i was a bravo bro i will not assign
well you could say
there are bravo bros and bravo bras
um or bravo i know we'll
cut it out uh so okay so but you're
you've you're so deeply entrenched in
the world of bravo that i'm not deeply
entrenched i'm gonna tell you i i never
watched
any of these housewives shows at all my
wife early on when we were dating yeah
that's right she got used to real real
housewives of new jersey and we have i
know you're not supposed to do this you
know as someone who's been in a lot of
successful relationships you're not
supposed to have a tv in the bedroom you
know because it takes away from intimacy
oh i didn't know that but
my wife and i have a television in our
bedroom and we watch a lot of tv
together yeah
in bed jerry you explained this to me
once and it makes perfect sense and by
the way i'm not at all judging you i
chris and i watch bat not together in
bed but we watch bachelor all the time
we're big you know bachelor nation
we're bachelor nationals
um so it makes sense
to that
yeah uh so i get why you watch it but um
i'm just i need your expertise
i watched i i i would watch new
new jersey which in its infancy
there was um was that hers another
another bravo liberty that's what we
call them a bravo liberty nick teresa
famously flipped the table and called
another
bravo liberty a woman named daniel stobb
referred to her as a prostitution
and it was really like sort of an iconic
reality television i call it unscripted
um
it was a change in the unscripted world
where it became
in my mind
well it just became sort of the new
dynasty it's where people went for
that sort of water cooler next day away
yeah did you see teresa
flip that table well listen
bethany was then a part of
a moment that uh some would say is not
as iconic but is right up there bethany
took a trip on something called scary
island
where
one of her co-stars
um
had a meltdown on a trip they took to
uh
some place like st barthers or or
something and it was nicknamed scary
island because
kelly benson was on real housewives of
new york yeah i know anthony got into
another big argument with another bravo
liberty from new york named jill zaran
it's a whole thing you guys have got a
way to do your homework oh yeah i didn't
see i didn't know that so i didn't know
that she you had mentioned because i
texted you before i did the interview
with her just looking for tips let me
just break down a couple things you got
to talk about okay it's too late we
already did it wait jerry jerry we
already did the interview
you said you were gonna call me before
you did this
no no no i said i was gonna call you
when we were recording the that we do
like and as you know you listen to the
show uh an outro for the bethany frankel
episode we already did the interview it
went great he's a fan of yours she's a
fan of yours she likes you we we just
you guys talk about it no
no no this is this will be part of the
episode
in theory okay
okay okay i'm gonna try not to be upset
that you didn't call me before you did
that i texted you you gave me good
advice
did you talk to her about carol
yeah i brought it up and she said you
know it's kind of old news i'm happy to
talk about it but it's
it's sort of old news
well it is all old news you know oh did
you um oh gosh i don't want to pry what
did you talk to her about
personal relationships uh a little bit
yeah a little bit she's single she's
going through she didn't i also didn't
want to pry i know that's not a
great trait for an interviewer
i don't know where you guys are i can't
keep up but let me tell you justin that
would be a catch for you
as a
relationship for a relationship
yes justin the woman
is
like always like she looks great just
going here
i started no resume she was very nice
very very successful she was very nice
and uh she she really spoke highly of
you jerry
yeah you run into each other in montauk
well that's where my parents live no i
know yeah
she said she ran into a long time ago
back in the back in the day like you
knew i i didn't know that you knew
her her or her father from back in the
horse racing days you had told me that i
know but she said you mentioned that to
her
right of course her father is a famous
uh trainer famous yeah yeah and she but
she had said see christian was um
chiding me for not picking up on this
pun because she had said her upbringing
in in this horse racing world was very
unstable
and she just wanted um
and i didn't pick up on it
a potential pun um
yeah i mean i don't know if your
listeners would have been like all into
that i think you know
they would have been more into like
what's going on with
carol
yeah she didn't she said
carol but she's not see i didn't know
this that she's not on the show anymore
she's having she's she's got a new show
coming out which um you should watch
this on hbo max i think
um
and she's got a podcast do you listen to
it
i i gotta say i've just been catching up
on like
uh lamone morris and i said tommy c and
yeah
just like jake johnson
what did they not get the podcast in
kenya
life is short
uh
see you're being sarcastic but i do
think you might listen i hope you listen
because
he's a fan of the show yeah you gotta
listen to this one
um well yeah and you know i should have
called you before i talked to her but
you gave me a really good advice and she
was she was great have you ever been on
watch what happens live with her on
andy's show uh never with her okay all
right all right we should all hang out
we was moving to greta yeah she's moving
to greenwich so when you come back to
new york chair did you talk about uh
being from fairfield yeah yeah i said
and uh she's gonna come i think we're
gonna try to get together in greenwich
or somewhere in connecticut so
so
i have they're good they're really good
oh you've had one yeah i don't know if i
have
another thing about bethany is bethany
in as an unscripted as unscripted
royalty
took her time on
real housewives
and turned it into an empire and really
yeah
set
the bar for what the lottery is in the
unscripted world i mean anyone who
is on
bachelor
or you know
paradise
show i mean i don't care if you were
you know if you're a contestant yeah
why should these people
put their personal lives out there for
everyone yeah
get something out of it yeah yeah
especially economic gain no i know i
don't think it should be about i mean it
depends on what you mean by bad or how
you define what your value system is but
no i mean
i she look i here's the thing i really
did respect about her is that she um she
used you parlayed this fame and whatever
current currency she has to um she
started a charitable organization that
is raising like 100 like tens of
millions of dollars for disaster relief
really cool
puerto rico
yeah guatemala
i did my research
[Music]
oh thanks
um jerry we love you so much uh when are
you coming back out here
the science guy not the actor guy
uh
um
all right we love you uh the show loves
you
and uh i'll hopefully see you soon
all right jerry but
and that's all the time we have
but um
uh on we should just change the title
the show to button
uh uh he's the best yeah it's been it's
been too long it's been way too long and
i've been since the quarantine
so he i you know listeners will know
that he
teases us and he teases the show but was
do you he was he naming those episodes
he was looking at his phone and
obviously and i'm not sure i was
wondering at first i thought maybe he
had he had listened to those episodes
that i realized he was just reading i
think he was just reading off his phone
but i i if i had to guess i would say he
listens at least sometimes i think he
does i think he does too
um but i want to think he does me too me
too sometimes because i really want his
support me too me too i really crave his
people yeah he he's the best and i do
actually wish i had called him before to
get some of that insight on uh real
housewives but i i think like you said
earlier it may have just derailed me and
i wouldn't may have been too proud about
it
you already knew too much i know the few
things i didn't know i was too proud of
celebrated yeah um wow let's read a
letter okay great i sent it to you yep
okay
uh here is the letter this is from kate
m
subject beatles quarantine and
w-y-r i always have to think about that
a hard time with w and y why is that i
don't know w is that
i don't know hi justin and christian
just listened to the intro on lamorne's
episode and had to hit pause to write
this
i am a die-hard beatles fan when my
peers were sporting nirvana t-shirts i
was wearing my beatles t-shirt when my
god i feel her yeah i i bet i'm the same
age as her yeah nirvana time when they
were probably like i was middle school i
was in junior high school
yeah that's when they really play and i
it's i didn't dislike them but i never
really grabbed hold of the current music
nervous i was much more to the beatles
me too but um then
you both have to
music at the time
oh that's a double um
christian had to explain that to the
shorties why we always do that so i'm
not gonna explain it to the show because
you know i might encourage some people
to become shorties
uh and what is it in a chat room in
facebook
uh when my chat room that sounds so
creepy oh really in a chat room
that's how long it's been
um when my peers were sporting nirvana
t-shirts i was wearing my beatles
t-shirt put that unplugged show
that nirvana unplugged is so good and
now nirvana is like great yeah great but
now they're like
it's like oldies i know at the time
i i don't know at the time i was into
like it was just too grungy
yeah you know i was into spin doctors
and like gin blossoms i like like kind
of more poppy night like counting crows
i love do you know steve kelly put out
that he did a cover of account and crow
song and he said it's 24 years since
that album came out it's the satellites
the uh
august and no no the one
the one before that or after that
the one just after that wow
anyway um i so back to kate um i was
wearing uh when my peers were buying up
tupac cds i was saving up to buy the
white album or listening to abbey road
my favorite non-stop god i just thought
of cassettes buying cassettes and ccds
and those the white album the double
[Music]
non-stop i feel her yeah abby
discovering abby road and white album i
i it like opened up a whole new world
like the whole world changed when
that's why that movie's so good that you
haven't seen yesterday i was born in the
wrong era when it comes to music i feel
uk
at any rate i can relate to justin's
love for yesterday ah i bawled after
watching it sat there for a good 10
minutes just sobbing by myself in the
dark living room in the middle of
quarantine it was such a good movie i
was like hearing the beatles songs
through fresh ears yes that's true
and imagining what it was like in those
early years when the world was
discovering their music
and it was a more and was a poignant
story i loved it one more beatles note
george is my favorite too oh
well i encourage you you may have
already seen it kate but uh watch the
dick cavitt interview with george really
incredible uh i'm working i'm a working
mother of four kiddos ages nine seven
six and three wow yeah wow my god
quarantine has been a roller coaster
with work then school going remotely so
suddenly so thankfully we're relatively
safe up here in vermont ah cool
and my kids went back to school full
time a couple of weeks ago and it was
like something clicked back in place in
their souls they are happier than i've
seen them in months i found you through
armchair expert ah once again thanks dax
and i'm almost all caught up your
podcasts keep me company as i work long
hours from my makeshift office in the
basement i've been a louis guzman fan
for a long time ah and i really love
this his episode i'm pretty sure i know
which tj maxx he was referring to louis
told a really funny tj maxx story uh a
story about how he was in tj maxx in
vermont in vermont yeah yeah uh and
winky face because it's probably only
one tg max in vermont or maybe not maybe
that's that's
i love your banter in the intro and
outro and hope my kids grow up to like
each other as much as the two of you
apparently like each other oh it's
really nice um finally a couple would
you rather's from my middle kids great
you know the ones from the kids we
haven't had in a while that those are
those are the best the best
okay first one would you rather only eat
plain cheerios
milk is allowed but nothing else or
plain oatmeal with nothing added no
fruit or maple syrup etc you know
i've actually faced this question more
often than you would think because um
i
when i work at the craft service table
you know when people are having their
breakfast and stuff i
issue breakfast for i usually have
oatmeal and i usually just have it
totally plain and uh i've considered
having cheerios instead but then you
gotta deal with the milk but in her case
she's saying eat plain cherries but you
can put you can make the oatmeal with
milk right
or can you only make it with hot water i
think just hot water she says plain
cheerios or plain olive oil mine is easy
well at the risk of sounding a little
douchey um
i love sentences that begin with i would
say
first of all it depends on if i can
change i know that she said plain
oatmeal but can i have different oh like
like fancy
fancy oatmeal like apple spiced no no no
that's not plain i mean like higher
quality or is it like a packet of quick
instant oatmeal if it is higher quality
like quaker oats no like you know that
they make fancy um people fancy like
rolled i'm not saying i need it but that
changed that was the same question okay
let's say it's just normal let's say
if it's quaker oats just from the
package i would choose not an ad um
cheerios
really yeah i like cheerios and milk a
lot you don't get milk oh i'm sorry milk
is allowed but nothing else oh oh yeah
but if my problem with the cereal fancy
oatmeal i think i might go fancy oatmeal
back in the day when i was when i was
eating a lot of cheerios as a kid i
would definitely say cheerios um but
i've come to appreciate the fact that
you can keep oatmeal out for a little
while and then kind of like go do some
stuff and come back to it and it might
be cold and whatever but it's still
edible and not cheerios just get nasty
and soggy could not disagree more i
think um oatmeal that's been left out
for too long gets disgusting and kingly
oh i don't mind the congeeli of it i'm
disagreeing with you yeah um whereas you
both have to have differing opinions
about oatmeal leavings being square
whereas cheerios and this might sound
gross but i prefer
soggy cheerios
to crunchy cheerios i love
that's weird milk logged cheerios hey do
you remember this i remember making a tr
this was such a treat
to make this for breakfast a little
pause granola past
our dad used to get granola from this
health food store and no we did not grow
up on the little house in the prairie
now our dad's granola a little bit on
the bottom
and then add the cheerios on top
milk and then a little dash of like
heavy cream oh yeah remember how
good that was good oh my god wow um
all right well yeah different would you
rather and then number two would you
rather would you rather be trapped with
a bunch of pirates
[Laughter]
i just imagined you with a bunch of
pirates oh it's funny you with a bunch
of guys i know me too i i wouldn't be
able i wouldn't know what to do would
you rather be i'd have to entertain i'd
be their gesture or something
i'd start like you would do what they
say yeah i would adapt you'd become
very submissive and
uh respectful yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay or i'd be like they're parrot wait
spencer i'd be like with a bunch of
pirates what's the question you'd rather
be trapped with a bunch of pirates for
the rest of your life or spend the rest
of your life alone in space pirates
uh pirates
trap but the word trapped you get to
like them i bet it'd be like trapped
seems to indicate that it doesn't matter
it's not good that they that they're not
looking at you favorably no but you
would you would be but still i would
still pick them even if even if my life
if the questions if the question was
spa in space alone or
being chased by angry murderous pirates
for the rest of my life i would still
choose the pirates because that's for
the rest of your life
by them yeah because that's still um you
would run out you would have a heart
attack
well assuming i didn't have a heart
attack it's a more exciting life it's
it's
much more variety would come from it
being alone in space is horribly
difficult horrible and um you know that
that movie moon is very difficult for me
to watch i i love it because and i also
love this amazing movie it's amazing if
you haven't seen it watch sam rockwell
highly recommend oh is that good but um
and it's all about existence and and you
know if you have any existential dread
it's like oh give me the pirates pirates
for even pirates who hated me well
because that's what i don't think they
would i think that i would you would
ingratiate
yeah i'd figure it out yeah
you because here's the thing you'd be so
non-threatening to the pirates you know
and if and if there were and you would
make yourself even less threatening like
if there were any
if you were competing for any food or
if there's a woman that you both liked
like you and a pirate
i wouldn't compete with a pirate for a
woman well the woman might prefer you
the pirate but there's there'd be
nothing you would just i would pretend
i'm gay
yeah but then
yeah well that's a whole other issue
then um
[Music]
yeah pirates me too okay great questions
great questions those are great yeah
um
keep up the good work and thanks for
keeping me company while i work from
home thank you kate uh ah essex junction
i want to visit there
essex junction vermont
um vermont continues to be okay it's
cool cool uh i miss it up there um i
wonder if she ever goes to bennington
the bennington the blue
red blue bird diamond
yes oh man do i miss vermont beautiful
and this time of year
anyway thanks kate and thanks to um
uh a friend of the show
mr gerry oc
frenemy of the show follow him on
instagram he's mr geriosi
and uh you know jerry if you're still
listening um he's definitely still
listening yeah
he's on the episode that's right he's
still listening
jerry uh never likes my instagram posts
really yeah i've noticed he likes mine
he likes everyone's wow hey i see i'll
go through instagram and i'll see
people that i know he doesn't really
even know that well and he's liking them
well you're experiencing you instant
insecure
it inst insecure secure yeah it is
making me insecure well if you guys want
to write into the show our email address
is life is short at wondering.com and
and jerry you can write in too and thank
you again to um our first real housewife
yes bethany franco uh
really nice getting to know her uh
meeting her and
look forward to the three of us uh me
bethany and jerry hanging out hopefully
one day yeah maybe i can come too you
know if you'd like you definitely like
to meet her okay then you're invited
thank you um and uh and you're all
invited to listen to uh this voice memo
coming up oh and if you haven't already
pretty good right that's pretty good um
if you haven't already i i hate when uh
people tell me to vote but i'm gonna be
a person to tell you to vote go go yeah
go vote yeah i mean god what a great we
we're so lucky we get to yeah uh just do
it it's election day yes that's right
happy election day happy night hope it
all goes smoothly yes and uh we will
talk to you all next week uh yeah and
and if you want to check out uh where to
vote how to vote uh
try when we all vote on instagram um and
uh
yeah
cool or i am a voter that's another good
source and uh stay tuned for voice memo
life could be a dream
you've been listening to life is short
life is short it's hosted by you justin
long why do i do that it's produced by
me christian law oh she's taking the
reins megan monaco
senior producer is michelle miesh lans
audio engineer is sergio enriquez with
executive producers
marshall louis edernan lopez for
wondering
[Music]
but these girls can't be like yeah it's
not possible right like maybe guys
doesn't like it they're never like wow
that sucks but what's the big deal yeah
yeah i'll find another guy and like
do their whole lives tonight now that
this guy's attracted to that i know it's
so weird
it really is so much just wrapped up in
their like success on the show right you
go they're like fame so so it all gets
channeled into him exactly and they make
it famous so badly that it makes them
obsessed with acquiring him
and he gives his car to him makes the
face
right and it gives them we're getting
closer to him at least and because of
that he has so much value that
and status that they are willing to
lower themselves and like they devalue
themselves and they'll and those and
they'll use their own personal pain
to get employees to get like
um
credit with him for the pursuit of
that famous life yeah yeah that's how
in a way it's a fascinating show it's a
fast
social experiment that this show exists
because
you're right it's not what are they
learning
in fact it's not
when the show first started it was
way more real it was like sure
on the show to like meet again maybe
meet a guy it's a fun way to like maybe
now it's like that is
i think such a small part of it oh yeah
it's like 10 of it and 90 of going on
the show now is like building your brand
and building your name and becoming
famous yeah and then like being an
influencer like that's like making it
yeah as a person like being on the show
been becoming famous it's everything
it's like the golden effect the golden
rule is carried like who cares that's
not how exciting that's true finding a
guy that's trying to go anywhere but the
thing with this show is about being
famous yeah it opens up it'll open doors
they know like what this will and that's
why they're like going after each other
right now because the stakes are so
right and that's why they're furious
with this girl for coming back because
he likes her more
that's crazy reaction but it's not crazy
when you start thinking about how
important and what the stake exists are
for them yeah that's why they're like
vicious towards this girl just getting
on the show is like a huge deal for them
that's how much they want to win this
you